how are you today where are you i
am in my house at my bar as you can see
yeah i was gonna say it's like you get
of all the places
let's do it at the bar uh that's
fantastic how has all this been
for you because i know that we're slowly
starting to kind of maybe get back to a
little bit
of regularness in our lives but how are
you
now coming out of this how are you
feeling i feel really good
honestly this this pandemic the
quarantine time
um in so many ways has been a blessing
for me
and uh from a musical standpoint i just
feel so inspired and feel like i've had
the time and the space to create music
and and really just
um kind of start my new phase post
busby yeah and uh what is the new phase
what is talk talk me through the the new
phase because
um what did you want to say on on
next girl i
yesterday marked a year that my producer
busby passed away
and i think that um it kind of forced me
to look at myself as an artist and make
sure that
whatever i followed i hope you're happy
now up with
was that 90s
sound throwback thing that he captured
so well with i hope you're happy now and
so next girl to me is
just me taking the first part of the
pandemic to
go back in and listen to
all of the ladies that made me want to
move to nashville and made me fall in
love with
music and with country music and it was
patty loveless and faith and trisha and
they sang these
girl anthems that were so iconic and
for me next girl is that yeah and i
think that just from a lyrical
standpoint every girl goes through this
probably quite a few times in their life
i know that i have i know my girlfriends
have and
i think judging just from uh the
response so far that other females have
encountered this as well yeah i want to
know what it's like
um because you you had been so open and
honest and forward with a relationship
both on social media and
in the press and then do you find that
you have to also be
that open honest and forward when a
relationship
ends to fans and to people where you had
spent so much time just speaking of each
other so lovingly
and then when it ends do you feel that
you're in that position of where you now
have to sort of talk
your fans and everybody through that
process of the relationship
i don't um obviously that was the time
of my life
and um i think that the
the details need to stay between the two
of us and um
i think that hopefully people respect us
to understand that
we are humans and i certainly didn't get
married to get divorced
um but things happen and and
you know i i i think it's just something
that has to stay between the two of us
um and i've felt the love of
fans and and appreciate that and i think
it's one of those moments
that you're a human it is and especially
when you're a country artist because we
all know
the relationship and the openness and
it's so everybody in all genres of music
has it with their fans
but there's something extremely unique
to country artists
with their fans where you can rely on
them
as actual people when you are going
through something
not just as fans but as people
and i think that's why i fell in love
with country music and i think that
if you listen to any of my music and you
listen to the stories and the way that i
tell
um just my stories through songs i think
that's
always been a huge part of it for me is
being honest and being authentic and
um this new music and next girl is no
different than that
and i wonder what it's like now because
we've all as you said it's a normal
thing we've all done it
and we rely on movies and music and
we've gone through this and we find that
one
song that gets us through it what is it
like now for you to be the one that
provides
that piece of art to somebody else who
may be going through this down the road
um it's crazy it's also
therapeutic for me yeah it helps
me you know i always say when i released
every little thing or when i released i
hope you're happy now or when i release
next girl
these songs are my babies these are my
true
my moments my life
that i'm telling you and they're helping
me
to feel like i'm not alone just as much
as i'm helping them to feel like they're
not alone and that's just a really
awesome
thing so you had mentioned earlier your
move to nashville how long ago because
your story was that you moved to
nashville and you were cleaning airbnbs
how long ago was that now
i moved to nashville 11 years ago in
january
of this past year and i was cleaning
airbnbs
i got when i first moved to nashville
and then i lost it and so it was kind of
like
in between so i would say i was like
cleaning airbnb six years ago five years
ago
and then and then fast forward to four
cma nominations
anybody who's out there cleaning toilets
with a dream you can do it too
that's what i want to know do you when
you're on that stage first of all
because there's so much to talk about
that even just that process
of standing there with luke combs as he
keeps saying your name over and over and
over again so first let's go to that
how do you not lose your mind and like
drop to your knees and die right there
well
i will tell you a lot of people who know
me
they were like how did you com like keep
composure
number one i had on a dress that if i
moved wrong i may have like had a
had a situation and would have been
horrible number two i had on heels
um and number three i was on national
television so i was like all right you
gotta like keep your composure but if
you notice in the thing
in the um video i like stomp my foot
because for me that was like the only
thing that i felt like i could do that
was like appropriate
and it seems to me with the cmas that
you can get a nomination maybe even two
but the idea of four is reserved
for people who i'm sure you idolize
what is it like to get four
it's i i had somebody say to me right
after it happened they're like you're
the most
nominated in new york
i don't even know how to explain it to
you like for me i never missed the cma
awards as a child
as a teenager as an adult i i
three years ago four years ago i went as
a guest of someone in the music industry
who was like a mentor and we were
sitting in the kind of like the
section behind the artist and he's like
you're gonna get there and then the next
year i was there and then last year i
was nominated once
and this year i'm nominated four times
it's just like i feel like i'm living
out like the cinderella story of like
yeah it's um i i also am just so
grateful that
it didn't happen for me overnight
because i think it makes these moments
like
way more special for me and just to know
everything that
i mean i almost moved home right before
every little thing so it's just
it's crazy who do you even as big as you
are with four nominations
who do you in your life still hope that
you make proud
like when this happens who do you
who do you hope is proud of you
oh gosh my parents they've
completely devoted their lives to help
me make this
um a reality for me and so i feel like
in a lot of ways this is
just as much for them as it is for me um
my grandparents that are um they've
passed on from cancer but this was their
dream that's the pierce name in my
family
and i feel like they're still with me um
my
team i mean i want to make them proud i
want to make my hometown proud i just
anybody who's ever believed that i could
do this i
i hope that i make them proud and um
going through isolation and everything
else i don't think that you're at the
age or the point in your career where
you've stopped
learning but what did you learn about
yourself through all of this
um
that i'm stronger than i thought
yeah is it not amazing that it took you
this to realize that
it's uh i will never forget 2020
um on so many levels but i really
i'm am
i could actually cry if i thought about
it long enough but i am
very proud of myself good
you should be you've done it you've done
incredible things
it's it's been a really cool just
evolution you never know what's gonna
happen and what
what things are gonna be thrown your way
and um
i just i'm really proud of just
as a person but also musically where i'm
at and just
everything that's unfolded i think in in
my
biggest moments of change even in the
11 years that i've been here it's been
those moments where i'm on the brink
of feeling like i can't i can't
go on that the most amazing things
happen to me and i feel like that's
gonna happen to me this year
um when you've had so much thrown at you
how does it feel to start throwing
things back
i mean it feels good i feel
i feel strong i feel like i'm making the
music that
i always wanted to make i feel
empowered i feel i feel
good and not perfect because i know that
that was a thing that you had talked
about on social
the idea of perfection is just not
something we should
be striving for right we just shouldn't
i think again this year more than
anything i've been like wow
even i just want to make sure always
that
it's so easy to look at artists like
myself or
whoever and think that their lives are
perfect or think that they
have everything together
they think you know everything about
them is perfect and it's just
not a reality for any of us and i'm just
trying to like
really i think when you go through a lot
of changes um
in every aspect of your life you kind of
just realize
imperfections are what make us all
ourselves and uh
i just want people to remember that and
uh i i'm
i'm friends with caitlin bristow i know
you're great friends with caitlyn
bristow
speaking of perfection what is your take
on how amazing she is on dancing with
the stars
okay caitlyn has become honestly one of
my
favorite things about 2020 has been um
my
relationship with caitlyn we have bonded
just and become instant i mean like just
really close
sisters i would almost say and i am
so proud of her i know she's had some
difficulties just with her injury
she is the most deserving i think she's
gonna
win the whole thing i think
she's gonna continue to just push
through this little injury that she's
got in this hiccup but i mean look at
what she's doing
with something that's obviously like
holding her back
she's killing so i am like team caitlyn
all the way
ice as soon as the cast was announced i
said she was going to win the whole
thing
like even before episode one i said she
was gonna win the whole thing
when she told us she was gonna be on it
i was like i don't care who's
you're gonna win like you're absolutely
gonna win so yeah
that's amazing and do you text like
what's that what's the chat like after
after the show what's what do you say to
her when she kills it on this on in the
ballroom
i mean i tell her constantly i check in
with her a few times a week i tell her
i'm praying for her because i know that
she's stressed out about the injury
because i know that's scary but i just
keep telling her like
you're gonna win you're gonna win you're
gonna win you're amazing like you keep
just keep being you because who she is
as a person and just her
natural ability to dance she's gonna win
hey i'm graham o'neill for more on your
favorite country stars click subscribe
or watch the videos
over there